[Music]
ever since he started playing he was a
superstar faker may be in trouble your
death mark tries to clean it up for ryu
oh look at the class look at the moves
faker what was that
faker often gets compared to players
like michael jordan for example who just
stayed good for what felt like forever
they are the undisputed best team in the
world the skt reign continues they win
their third world championship
the skt dynasty is over all hail the new
kings samsung galaxy but for the man
himself he hasn't tasted that sort of
defeat in the better part of three years
the greatest team in the history of
league of legends taken down by the
greatest team europe has ever produced
[Applause]
it's been five years since faker has won
a world championship since t1 has won a
world championship it has been a while
and they are trying to reclaim that
ultimate title he graciously
transitioned from the superstar of the
team
to
enabling all of these you know young
carries and young talent showmaker's
still alive khan still alive baker
trying to finish the job she'll make a
running for his life he's joking he's
diving he's finding a way out but
kobayashi comes in with the bullet to
find the kill t1 on the knife's edge
khan still standing so much life steal
but it will not be enough t1 take the
fight owner and faker standing strong
it's a bloodbath at the dragon t1
hey folks before we get into the video i
just want to remind you to please hit
the sub button and turn on notifications
if you haven't done it yet because it
really does help okay so faker is
unquestionably the best league player of
all time there have been players that
have made amazing plays it's the
consistency that faker made them and
over so many years that's the thing that
makes faker so ludicrous and i think why
faker often gets compared to
players like michael jordan for example
who just stayed good for what felt like
forever and i think faker has has done
that and he's still not finished that's
the thing that's absolutely terrifying
he's a three-time world champion with
nine domestic titles his name is
synonymous with league both in south
korea and around the world and most
importantly faker remained dominant for
years no matter how many other talented
players burst onto the scene faker was
always a threat the key thing about
faker wasn't that he was really good for
one year because we have a ton of those
players you know you could argue that
the shy in 2018 was like the greatest
player to ever play the game
but faker just kept doing it and yet
despite looking unstoppable year after
year the winds started to slow down for
faker the last time he won worlds was
all the way back in 2016 and that fourth
world trophy has eluded faker for years
looks like gen g
on the backs of a 27-minute game are
gonna be making it to the friday matchup
up against griffin it was close here in
five games but 10 g they're able to pull
it out and everyone at the next sun
arena and you in the chat were there
when the dream died for sk telecom t1
the run that saw them hit three
consecutive world finals win two out of
three 2015 2016 before falling to then
samsung galaxy now gen g
does end today in his prime faker
undoubtedly could hard carry his team
any time he needed to but not even a god
to your player can keep winning forever
ever since he started playing he was a
superstar
and having to carry that
for this amount of time without it
breaking your back
is absurd while faker remained the one
unchanging constant in t1 the org kept
shuffling players around him hoping to
find the roster that could once again
give him the backup he needed and in
2019 they put together a juggernaut the
2019 super team was when you introduced
players like teddy and mata really
started to shake things up a little bit
um [ __ ] as well was you know really
exciting when he first joined skt i
don't think things necessarily worked
synergy wise but as far as the raw
mechanical talent
poof
out of control
levels of power unfortunately at that
year's worlds this discombobulated squad
of amazing individual performers didn't
stand a chance against a notoriously
tight-knit g2 this is his hero moment if
he wants to turn this fight in favor of
team this could be the game
[Music]
vladimir they can't do it this is it the
greatest team in the history of league
of legends taken down by the greatest
team europe has ever produced that
devastating loss at worlds 2019 left t1
without a lot of options the superstar
roster broke up and with only faker left
the team decided to try something a
little different 2020 was a rebuilding
year t1 surrounded faker with a bunch of
rookies from their academy roster in the
hopes that his wisdom and experience
would help them develop on stage
[Music]
despite all of faker's excitement about
his young teammates 2020 turned out to
be a bit of a wash for t1 they won the
spring playoffs but then faltered in
summer and missed worlds so once again
it was time to shuffle the roster and
this time it really seemed like faker's
time at the top was basically done
people weren't exactly expecting much
from t1 by the time 2021 started after
all the roster shuffling some began to
wonder if maybe faker was actually the
problem it wasn't that he was bad but
maybe he just couldn't bring in the wins
like he used to some people even went as
far as to call him washed and it began
to look like maybe the goat was finally
past his prime with young talent nipping
at his heels showmaker is a better mid
laner at the moment scout is a better
mid laner at the moment like there are
you know a lot of players that are
individually better than faker but no
one comes close to the career that this
man has even faker himself felt like he
wasn't performing as well as he should
have been and chose to spend a few weeks
on t1's bench at the start of the season
but faker didn't stay idle for long he
returned to the main lineup to help the
team secure a fourth place finish at the
spring finals and while fourth place
obviously wasn't where they wanted to be
it allowed them to find the weaknesses
in their playstyle and work on them
going into the summer
[Music]
towards the back line another equalizer
this one not as fantastic as paranoia
gets towards the back line faker has to
hold out as tanner has just ripped apart
the front line and teddy's there
tidy up it's a double kill for canna and
the acape is a surprise
ghost arrow okay trying to get on in
there but here comes baker and look at
the emperor's divide he gets three and
this is the team fight t1 we're looking
for this is what we have been talking
about as the damage is not enough to
take out showmakers somehow he gets out
of there as the gwen is going insane i'm
not sure dominique want to take this
fight over the course of the season
faker started taking more and more of a
mentorship role in t1 he graciously
transitioned from
the superstar of the team
to
enabling all of these you know young
carries and young talent slowly but
surely t1's roster of hungry young
players improved faker was leading them
to glory game after game and while they
ended up placing second in the summer
playoffs there was hope
willer with that one and the ofelios is
going to just steal away the drake they
are going to get a nice amount of damage
on the carrier here
as there is the aoe coming out from gumi
you see he's just standing his ground
and being a turret in his own right he's
able to take down willer
you can see that faker is kind of just
corralling them all into the river here
he's totally buying east cassidy with
ever frost nobody's ever be going to be
able to lock him down now she will chase
down morgan it's going to be good to
zone him and def he doesn't have a
splash and there's no reds available and
just like that azir is the most
dangerous champion on the rift as nobody
can approach him now they zone him away
toby no flash for him either
and he will try to get some damage in
but it will not be quite enough as the
flash is coming in and owner is just
taking names here as dow will go the
zillion that's a baron huge fight win
for t1 this gigantic fiego is on the
chase he's looking for more we got mr
200 years on the opposite side goomy you
see trying to make it but gets it going
and faker is trying to 1v4 now and he
will be able to he's creating the front
line for goomba you see
on the ophelios and he's going to keep
this fight alive led by faker t1
finished first at the lck regional
finals qualifying for worlds as the
third seed from korea and they had a lot
to prove on a league's biggest stage
they'd have to face international
superstars square off against domestic
rivals and show the world that faker
wasn't just a great player he was also a
great teacher
and when worlds kicked off t1 finally
unleashed all of its fearsome potential
its desperation plays non-stop when the
chances just keep slipping and slipping
away from your hands t1 with a statement
game for the first game of world 2021
and now the nexus is open the nexus will
drop and t1 in under 30 minutes take
down their primary competition t1
will 3-0 harm or life esports they
wanted to do this in the world's
gauntlet thankfully they got a second
try and damn
second time was the job t1 blew through
the group stage and the quarterfinals
and entered the semis to face their
biggest challenge yet their next
opponent was damwan the defending
champions the team that snatched the
summer trophy out of t1's grasp just a
couple of months earlier the team that
supplanted t1 as league's current
dynasty the team that had yet to lose a
single game at worlds even though it was
only the semi-finals many people saw
this match as the real grand finals of
the tournament the ultimate clash of
league's south korean titans you know t1
has so many titles to their name but
it's been five years since faker has won
a world championship says t1 has won a
world championship it has been a while
and they are trying to reclaim that
ultimate title getting lower and lower
could all come down to a single line a
single smite faker over the wall 16.
it's massive faker off to the back side
keep your eyes on that one they find the
reset that's going to be one frozen
thrall is now coming out don juan kia
getting rounded in the river but canyon
is still standing strong for a moment no
double triple for guber you see
follow-up kill us might steal from owner
the rookies
are making their market world showmaker
wants to make a play but not today sit
down show maker this is team one's time
carry on game carrier now stepping
forward looking for the double bomb
carrier locked up where's the ultimate
going to go but now kumushi untouched
owner immediately into the back line
buying as much time as possible but it's
two quick kills for t1 and here come the
curtain call it's like a rinse and
repeat of game two but in the back side
showmaker finds one tries to find the
stair tries to find the faker turning it
back faker finding one kill gonna look
for a little bit more that's a three out
of rise ghosts running for the hill and
t1 with confidence taking the fight t1
they fight well to bring us to match
point but they'll get knocked down in
game four t1 holding on for as long as
they can but they know this one is over
don juan kia pushing in breaking the
brace show maker legendary a triple kill
to finish and don juan kia will bring us
to game five t1 handed the tournament
favorites their first losses at worlds
but the fight wasn't over yet connor now
stepping forward 3k getting lower
you're trying to lock up who's gonna get
it no in the end it is canyon when it
matters most you will find this fight
for guma usually standing strong on the
back side it does not matter and the
face of the elder darwin kia will wipe
t1 off the map they're gonna tp top as
well they have the elder dragon they
have a wave they have everything they
need to go to the world finals and damn
old legends and old legacies goodbye
faker goodbye t1 hello dom juan and show
maker they will defend their title in
the finals and look to go back to back
t1 may have lost the deciding battle but
even making it as far as they did was a
testament to the quality of the team's
players and to faker's ability to steer
them in the right direction he may not
be quite the unkillable middle lane god
he once was but faker reinvented himself
and found a new groove by using his
experience to enable the next generation
of league's greats
everyone is just under this this
incredible leader that is faker and the
fact that
it makes sense on paper right but not
everyone's built to be a leader this guy
was built to play league of legends and
it didn't seem like he was going to be
the guy that was going to be capable of
of leading the team but he absolutely
was after yet another overhaul t1 is
ready to face the new season and this
time they know exactly who should be
leading the charge
has spotted him out here as the tower is
going to fall down great grand entrance
is going to connect onto kyoto but he
has the old to keep himself alive bacon
now gets underneath the turret
immediately has to use the open it does
not matter that's a triple kill might be
time to revive the hashtag the things
faker does
some people even went as far as to call
him washed and it began to look as if
perhaps the goat was finally past his
prime with hot young talent breathing
down his neck boy that sounds a lot more
erotically charged when i say it out
loud huh it's a real real steamy league
of legends fantasy